and the Boston Celtics are devastated by
the tragic passing of Kobe Bryant his
daughter Gianna John Altobelli Carrie
Altobelli ELISA Altobelli Christina
Mouser Sarah Chester Payton Chester in
eras of ahin all lost this past Sunday's
horrific helicopter accident a brilliant
and passionate player Bryant was a
five-time NBA champion with the Los
Angeles Lakers the team with whom he
spent his legendary 20-year career
Kobe displayed a relentless approach to
a game he dearly loved and will always
be remembered as an integral player in
the storied history of the Boston
Celtics and Los Angeles Lakers rivalry
in honor of his life and the lives of
all the victims we ask you to please
join us in a 24-second moment of silence
which will be followed by a video
tribute celebrating Kobe's life and
career
this place was always special to me for
my first for the first time I came into
the league it was special you know I
don't think fancy really understand how
much they drove me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
history's is what I think makes the city
different than all the rest
[Music]
the first basketball jersey I've ever
had was Kobe Bryant Kobe Bryant was the
reason I started playing basketball
always was and will be you know my
favorite player of all time
[Music]
if you do the work you work hard enough
dreams come true
[Music]
it's not the destination it's the
journey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]